hi there reject nation greg and john
here today we're gonna watch the bad
batch
episode six called decommissioned i hear
it's a good one
so i'm excited hey hit that like button
if you end up enjoying our video
or just to be kind right away subscribe
click that notification bell to get
notified
when our next reaction is up also full
length watch long is where you sync up
with the time code over at our patreon
page we're over there we cover many
shows with the same tier you get the
option for both reaction highlights and
watch logs
included it's a good time plenty of
alcohol and other substances required to
enjoy yourself gotta thank for thom
jindal
for editing these highlights for us
you're a good man now
let's get wrecked while watching this
tech
because we've been hunting the
chamber echo of
this star wars got it we got it in our
crosshairs
and and now i am the omega of this
channel for interrupting you
i'm gonna go get into some mystery
[Music]
nice opening shot
[Music]
sorry oh she's practicing
keep your eye on the target
got it again but i've already hit the
target
three times out of twelve that's luck
omega
not skill so i'll just need to be
consistent
[Music]
[Laughter]
practice
you have to learn to tune out
distractions which comes
with practice again it's sort of like
those muppet characters on the balcony
stellar and waldorf no
kermit and miss piggy miss piggy
gonzo and fozzie i assume you boys
know what a tactical droid is they were
the opera the operational brains
tactical droid intel has tremendous
value
which is why you're going to break into
this decommissioning facility on
corellia
and retrieve one beef han solo
[Music]
build up your strength
wow lesson over badass
yeah they should bring her along so
megan needs to weight lift
this feels like it's going to be a
darker episode that's when the bad batch
is
awesome yeah
getting a little bit of those rogue one
vibes again
they're operating on a rotating quadrant
scan if timed correctly
there's an entry point in their blind
spot follow me
vertigo good perspective shot enhanced
clone who's afraid of heights
[Music]
cool
it's kind of like that droid factory and
attack the clones
just throw a reference you know
reference yeah whatever echo
tech we'll locate and retrieve the droid
wrecker
cover us up top but be on the lookout
was crosshair's job
what about me what should i do stay here
and keep your eyes peeled for the target
let's move she's got a job she's gonna
do just that
mm-hmm she's gonna stay right here
it's ain't gonna cause any trouble
yeah we have one shot at this let's get
it right
off loaded
[Music]
the droid's already in pieces
there's a person behind you omega oh
someone just ran off with the droid head
i see him one of the workers is still in
our target
i'm on it
[Music]
take it easy kid i don't want to hurt
you
but i can't have you getting in the way
she's the
she's one of the sisters from um the
ahsoka storyline in clone wars
uh the last season that's cool you're
gonna see that earlier oh they're
both here okay
who are you who am i
you oh cool okay
you win why don't you ease up on that
thing and
we can talk about it
especially with another ahsoka show to
advertise
grab a weapon i had one
so like neil blom camp droids yeah
[Music]
lifted
[Music]
no omega they could be your friends
hope you're not expecting gratitude
should i've let the george shoot you
badass
[Music]
oh it's such a cool looking episode
i have the droid head hot potato
you shorted out the entire system you
override the lockdown
control pin
[Music]
i can't reach the platform it's the only
way to reboot the whole facility
figure it out yeah it's easy for you to
say
you gotta wreck your fears
[Music]
you got this you're tough
this poor guy's head's been in pain for
like three episodes no
he's got a brain tumor take that
no show you're good by helping her
online
do you see good soldiers that's what it
sounded like to me oh no
the chips becoming activated oh no
[Music]
oh so i think it happens
so soon no not record
push it away man
i need help i'm on my way
[Music]
what are you doing i'm taking down the
support posts
[Music]
damn yo this is a cool episode yeah dude
it's an awesome operation
[Music]
dude this music is awesome
come on oh
god
it's toy story 3 all over again
yeah my man
[Music]
thank you you're welcome if we want to
get out of here we need to work together
but i still don't like you i'm used to
it oh man i
love the look of this episode yeah the
lighting is gorgeous very cinematic
a larger wave of police droids is headed
our way
we need a conversion what we need is a
diversion
is there an echo in here yes yes
okay echo we need a distraction
what's that thing gonna do we need an
army to get out of this
and we happen to have one
cannot it didn't work
it will once we boost the signal
and this will help me access the program
just push it like emotions
never acknowledge them you just need a
little more time
i just picked it up
[Music]
oh damn oh damn
zombie droid army
it's like the toys from sid's house and
toy story
taking revenge
nice work r7 we're ready for a pick-up
[Music]
or seven
no no
yes doing it yeah she built up her arm
strength
all in this past 10 minutes
yeah those george and this lighting look
at it from the game anthem
wait what about us
[Music]
that's ahsoka's droid for nothing
whoever sids buyers isn't gonna be happy
you knew how dangerous the information
on the tactical droid is but you didn't
know who you were giving it to
we're being paid to acquire and deliver
not ask questions
our contact needed that information to
fight back against the empire ahsoka
right
why aren't you fighting for the empire
isn't that what you clones do now
not all of us we are different
yeah i've heard that before keep working
on that ball kid
i will bye here
what's this tech copied the tactical
droid's intel to this data rod before it
got destroyed
why are you giving it to us you'll use
it for the right reasons
huh maybe you are different
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
it's clear which episodes they really
throw down for yeah
we acquired the tactical droid data from
corellia
and we had help it was a squad of rogue
clones
and i know where to find them thought
you might want to know
reverse shot reverse shot
oh yeah it's definitely her i'd be a
million percent surprised if it's on her
at this point yeah too many too many
clues
for one there are episodes in clone wars
were with us okay
so that's just one clue
they had r7 there yeah i'm so bad with
names i had to see the droid to be sure
all right cool it's okay better than me
yeah man i think that was actually uh
that you know what i really like about
that episode a lot
is i felt something that i haven't felt
with any of the other episodes
uh thus far um i really felt the sense
of peril for the situation they were in
like they were really
in a a tight spot and it was like
i know they're gonna be fine but i
actually felt the stakes this time and i
like you could feel the uh overwhelming
amount of police droids who were just
bombastic uh you know cornering them and
it just seemed like it wouldn't stop in
the situations they were running into
like with omega
um be about to be like completely
incinerated
uh record dealing with the whole thing
and i'm surprised no one's had the
conversation about like him bringing up
he's burned up a couple times now with
his head yeah and this was the most
overt
way they have displayed that yeah it's
like we
were a lot of us have been saying and
speculating that
it's most likely uh the order 66 chip
going off in his head and then you know
in this
episode it's very apparent that that's
what's happening
especially when we started saying good
so it wasn't even clear at first i liked
that the way they handled that was a
good soldier good soul but
like did he say good and then once you
get a clear identity of the dialogue
you're like oh damn it's happening right
now yeah yeah
um so i don't know something about him
is still
pushing it down and hasn't fully
activated so
i think i think with the wreckers chip
they're making you go it's it's going to
happen they're letting the audience know
that it
it's it's on its way but i think you
know
tech echo one of them will be able to be
like
this is what's happening we need to
figure out a way to prevent it from
fully
taking over him yeah you know we already
lost crosshairs we can't lose
uh wrecker now too yeah so in that
moment i was like
oh no i don't want this to happen yeah
and i mean i feel like that act
actually really helped like in some uh
you know executions that could have been
you know
trite but i feel like it helped to ramp
further up the
tension like you said i mean this
episode already has this intensity about
it and then to have him overcome with
that
you know it helped you know it's like
we've joked i feel like in the past
couple episodes about like oh it's
coming and nobody seems to be commenting
on the fact that he's having these
obvious headaches
but yeah they made something very
engaging out of it here and then you
know also a great
you know moment of relief and triumph
for him to actually at least for the
moment overcome it and step back in and
join the battle and everything
but it also seems perhaps like you know
they could be
using that as a potential like whenever
that comes to a head they're going to
have to address it tech or somebody's
going to have to take a look and
maybe in addressing that after whatever
mess or set piece comes of it because
this wrecker you know
he's big and boisterous and if he were
to turn that would
be a pretty difficult thing to just
physically deal with and so i
imagine after whatever happens there
it's probably going to give them some
kind of
key in an insight into how they could
maybe
uh save you know and reclaim crosshairs
you know well i think the show on an
emotional heartstring level did a really
solid job
um in a visual display something that i
i'm not even sure
this is something that maybe you didn't
notice and maybe i'll get some kudos for
saying something kind of cool here uh
here's what it is guys
so wrecker is struggling and the whole
gang
is like how do we get out of here you
know like you got trace
and rafa and then the bad batch omega
they're all
they're all stuck here and then you got
wrecker up there who's going through the
the order 66 ordeal
and then when he comes down he literally
saves the day and by just
doing his thing of
not using any wit just being a wrecking
ball
and it works saves the day and it goes
to show you that it would be a
major loss more than just the fact that
we like wrecker
that visually shows you the necessity of
having him
you know like crosshairs is a like a
necessary character
but they've obviously been able to do
without him and
readjust without him where would wrecker
like
he's they kind of showed more of a
necessity to have him in
on the bad batch team more than even
crosshairs uh
like with that moment so i thought that
was a really like solid way to make you
go
i like the drama of showing that it can
happen but i don't want it to fully go
there
yeah i know absolutely yeah and so it
increases both the physical peril at the
time
so yeah the emotional peril looking
forward and everything and on a
technical
level everything here just looked like
great whenever they go for the dark
episodes like the more heavy episodes
they really seem like they throw down
a lot more for those episodes in
particular because
this looked excellent and i noticed i i
say this more with
the episodes that have a darker tone to
it and yes a darker look overall
it's a darker look i think it makes it
look more cinematic because i feel like
this bad bat show is
kind of been alternating between two
different kinds of shows
like the the more the more matu and
clone wars kind of did that too
where you would have like more of the
kid-friendly ones and then you would
have like the really heavy
uh you know high-stakes action-intense
dramatized ones
and and those and for bad back it's very
evident i think all fans would probably
agree that those episodes tend to click
better as just a viewing experience
especially and like you could
you kind of just hear it with the music
too like the way the
the the mixture and the attention to
detail on on certain music cues to throw
in there to elude
like when wrecker was going through uh
when they cut back to him for a second
they did cue some of the uh that
haunting ominous
music that plays with certain parts of
this it's so subtle and underneath but
it's like
it's like an audio indicator of this is
what's really happening to him you know
it's like whenever uh they get a new
composer for a star wars movie and they
throw a hint
of the imperial margin you know just to
re-brand
everything back into the yeah the
continuity yeah
dude it's great and then um so this
uh rafa and trace i believe trace
is the the younger one
um basically what happened is in clone
wars
season the final season when ahsoka
i i only saw it once so i'm going off of
member here
when soca uh she was one of her look if
you're gonna ask me for
names of items and people i'm not sure
guy uh
but i am one to go i know where that's
from and i know what that is
but i didn't tell you what it's called
it's good very cool
one of her bikes her star wars bikes it
was in need of repair
and then um at one of the like the lower
level slumps of coruscant
is where rafa and trace resided and
she had that she was trace was helping
her uh
fix her bike up and then it led to like
some missions
because uh rafa the older sisters
it like does deals with bad
bad space people and we're like you know
transporting spice across the universe
and they're trying to make
right decisions along the way and then
and you know being a jedi
uh they didn't like jedi's and so then
she
does they develop a friendship and i'm
giving you a summary of like four
episodes
and see
but basically ahsoka develop develops a
very strong
bond with the sisters and a very uh
important one for them and it was
something i remember
that some fans weren't big fan some fans
didn't take
a huge liking to having those episodes
there
uh for my recollection i personally
enjoyed them
and so i um i was cool with seeing them
back here again so when they're saying
the contact
like it's got to be so good they got the
droid and
um and also in rebels ahsoka
she had like a code name where she was
helping out the rebels
for a while before it was officially
revealed like oh this secret person is
actually
ahsoka so i think this is the beginning
of
that you know um
i'm sure they're fleshing that out as
well because this really does feel like
the in-between show to truly because
there's like a
there's clone wars and rebels and
there's a big gap in there and this is
the gap
yeah yeah okay that makes sense yeah and
uh so i think they're using that
opportunity
because then you got like mandalorian
too which is using that gap with fennec
and then you're showing and i think this
is where you're going to get that ahsoka
storyline of working with them but
trace and ruffle aren't in rebels so i
don't know if you come to them
they're going to die in this show i
don't think so that's not how these
shows go it's not a star wars work
no no one ever truly dies yeah
i don't know i could be wrong you know i
doubt that you're wrong
uh it just it seems like that's the uh
it seemed obvious in all the ways to get
a fan excited of like ahsoka's coming
and i think at this point you'd be kind
of disappointed if it wasn't ahsoka
considering every
everything hints towards it being her
yeah i feel like
at that point unless you have something
even better to reveal it would just make
people upset
yeah yeah especially because people do
spend so much time combing
and recognizing you know the little
details and stuff like that i feel like
i don't know if you do too much like
poking at people and trolling people
then you're going to make a mess
trevor's lottery uh rough boner
boner bad bone
but not man this was awesome this is
really like really
it felt kind of like a western or
something like that like a shootout in a
corral or something like that except
with a
hyper detailed robot destruction
site well there's like gripping action
in here too
and uh the action was really cool it was
like the coolest hunter's ever been
and i i even like the
uh like on a plot point level you're
like
it's pretty obvious that omega will
probably by the end this episodes are
using
her bow and arrow which that looks that
[ __ ] looks so familiar to me and i can't
i don't know
where it's like if someone were to tell
me
where that's the bow and arrow we've
seen before if someone tells me i'm
gonna like feel like an idiot because
i'm like of course i should have been
able to pinpoint it because right now i
can't pinpoint it
but i've i'm like that that seems very
familiar to me
we must have seen it at some point in
clone wars from one of the characters
uh i don't know or maybe
maybe jedi fall in order it's hans it
belongs to hans
who did not appear in this episode even
though they're at corellia
they should have done it it's messed up
uh but yeah man that was uh
it was great the the action was really
cool this was firing on all cylinders
guys leave your thoughts down below for
what you thought about this episode
have you been liking the bad batch is
the bad batch been going better for you
where would you rank this one in
particular leave your thoughts down
below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that thumbs up button
or if you really didn't like the video
you can hit that down vote
you know it's okay to disagree with us
and if you want to be a dick about it
fine be a dick wreck
our day
tyler haig tyler hag listen buddy you
know you know what i like to do i like
to take
people and measure them into the video
and and i just thought you would be
perfect
because that's you know what i'm here to
deconstruct this shout out for you so we
met a shout out
and uh it's gonna be a great experience
for you especially
because you are the wrecker of this bad
batch my friend and if you were going
through some kind of
perilous head trauma i would be so sad
because not only would you be perfectly
clutch as a member of our
team you know going in smashing droids
and stuff with your big
muscly arms and whatnot but you're also
just a fun-loving
sweetheart of a guy and i would hate to
lose you as an asset to the bad batch
that is our patreon
i would hate if you died too tyler i
don't want you to die
don't die tyler jeez what's wrong with
you stay alive
thanks for living and being with us
till the end bye tyler wisconsin